hello and welcome to see you're playing
spicy and I solando I said some exotic
like no and that just looks like Iceland
sometimes there are those okay the
triangle it's one of my favorite lines
he actually what 97 is uncommon and I
should have gone to have four maybe ok
f6 what is f six aha that's the point
come on really you're sacrificing that
porn for real yep yes okay
ok check
yeah it's not just a pawn I mean the
whole structures down the drain
poor numbers number two black resigns
what's happening here it's a second win
in a row way after I spent like 40
seconds Jack yeah okay well he just
loses here after move seven I mean the
position is already already a bad and
this is strategically very bad the open
sea file and he says sorry for playing
so badly yeah well sometimes sometimes
it just happens yeah we we kind of
completely are completely off and check
yes it just it just losing what can't
you do they're five porn is also rather
important because it keeps the whole
position kind of together and without it
like this game has no a kind of
foundation at all of course you can do
this here for example but it's a pawn
and end the better structure you know
you cannot just that 97 and then f 6 +
f5 is probably not not a playable
playable opening for for black okay
thanks for watching